and coordinates
must be very frustrating for mabajara
because like he probably knows he has to
win this game then yeah and he tried in
the opening then he was losing and now
it's like okay my positions got better i
can't really resign it's kind of
position i kind of want to resign but
now i now i'm not even a piece down i've
got to play on he's kind of missed his
opportunity to resign because he he
can't you know he can't resign now and
he he can't really win now so it's like
i mean there's still 250 dollars on the
line for yeah it's true true that's got
a lot of money see drawing a loss yeah
might not save him either way in the
tournament but a little bit of extra
pocket money quite a nice bit of pocket
money yeah yeah
and uh okay a bit of a threat black's
rook was threatening to take the white b
pawn due to a pin but white's king now
on the ideal square
and this check okay now he's going to
end the game i say that and he resigns
white was about to win a third pawn the
black king in big trouble and majority
of resigns
wow that means shakira
he is knocked out of the tournament